I have this problem when I have a friend
crush I will not say anything I've never
heard of this term before because
whenever I see someone that I want to be
my friend I go ask them to be friends hi
I'm Steven I am extremely awkward yeah
that's true
feel like Stevens the kind of guy do you
have like a fourth impression of cuz he
was just like hanging out for a while
and you're like Oh Stevens here oh my
gosh can you help there you don't really
know exactly how to interact with him
like there's like a rhythm in a group
and then Steven just kind of maybe takes
a while to warm up to people uh who
wants to have a conversation with Steven
he's a little guarded so I finally
decided it's time to just get some help
for the next week I'm gonna hire a life
coach to help me get over my awkwardness
and make new friends just so I'm clear
what you would like in this coaching you
really want to develop your social
skills and have more friends yeah
sometimes I do feel paralyzed and I feel
awkward of situations where I'm supposed
to make conversation do you remember
when that first started um when I was in
seventh grade I was walking to the bus
stop and there was this like pretty
blonde girl and as I got closer she
started waving it and she said hi for
some reason I thought that the way she
looked at me was as like a nerdy Asian
chubby boy and she was like showing pity
to me I hated that I don't know why did
this but I like look at her and I walked
past her and I walk all the way to the
next bus stop other people that struggle
socially with relationships have
difficulty with what we call social
cognition putting yourself in someone
else's shoes being able to anticipate
how might they might think or feel or
react what happens in our childhood or
anytime if we have a big event it can
become kind of an identity we wear but
clearly you're not just that so if you
start with just saying hi to people and
I'm gonna support you yes I'm weak yeah
I'm gonna be phoning you and thinking
that all just as an experiment
you're not trying to get it all right
you're just saying what happens but
after that session with Deborah where I
opened my heart up and did not expect
any of them I caught up the most social
person I've ever met
Keith to give me some challenges that
would force me to become more social you
want to learn how to make friends I'm
great at making friends talk to somebody
new every day a good conversation
doesn't have to come from the first
person you talk to the first person you
talk to may be busy
how's it going guys pretty good guys
going somewhere I'm pretty sure they
thought I was gonna rob them what is
happening too many people hi girls me hi
Stephen
I went to the canteen where like all the
employees kind of hang out and then I
just kind of froze as soon as you've
noticed that feeling whenever you can I
want you to just feel your feet on the
ground I just take a couple of breaths
to feel your body again and then notice
what you want to do becoming more social
just have to be becoming someone else
what would be an authentic way to reach
out to something it you can Toronto okay
just cuz I saw the shirt there yeah yeah
you Toronto fan nice nice I'm from Ohio
actually Stephen nice to meet you guys
you guys just visiting LA yeah yeah cool
myth yeah me too or no actually I live
in LA now find somebody that you want to
be friends with and engage them in
conversation Zack Evans Zack Evans he
loves having friends I could see why
you'd want to be friends with him
I do do you start a conversation it's
not your responsibility how the
conversation goes so it could be like
hey Derek you play basketball you want
to pick up a game sometime and you might
say no not really you're like okay great
oh it goes it is it's awaking yo what up
what's up man
Kings and Cavs playing
really yeah that's like my team raise
your team no we should we should play
who should really yeah I'll tell you oh
ho I'm not you're not mentally you're
cool you're a cool guy
you believe that I actually do when he
first came here I wasn't sure about you
and slowly I started to come in a huge
video yeah one of the things that we're
constantly looking for when we're having
conversations with other people is
common interest I'm gonna make that shot
act over there this is for you all right
this was the clown comes in and slips on
oh shoot I should fire pick that up cool
this was good chatting green stuff you
just hang out yeah yeah so I got some
banana on you I bet I want you to go to
a bar
find somebody buy them a drink talk to
them see if you can get them to buy you
a drink
I will need your emotional support like
this want me to go please great yeah I
go to a bar you're just gonna walk up to
somebody say something very
inconsequential like like I love you no
no like it's a Patrick's Day I hate bars
why do you hate bars because there's
people there and it smells and it's dark
the whole purpose of a bar is to make it
easier for strangers to meet otherwise
you drink at home much rather drink at
home and talk to people on facebook chat
that is the least personal way to
connect with someone do you think people
go to bars and they're like already
willing to converse what you're gonna
come on and come on yo man
are you doing good I don't know I don't
think so I'm just saying hi probably not
unless you live in Studio City find some
sort of common interest from there you
do this thing that we call trading
information which is when you're having
a good conversation it kind of goes back
and forth between the two people okay
I've run by there the other time hey let
me buy you drink man
first I have it what do you want that
guy was so nice yeah most people are
pretty nice I don't believe in people
you don't believe in people I just
assume that everybody hates people like
I did
Thank You Keith no it's probably the
mustache French hang out with each other
and friends invite their friends into
each other's lives so you should have
somebody like come over to your house
and hang out I have a confession I have
never had anyone over at my apartment
before
well you then have someone over what's
up oh I don't know oh I don't only know
what people do in the hangout so I've
made some pizza yeah yeah and I also got
some beer yeah yeah yeah dude yes like
here I love it
oh yeah I don't like here do you have a
bottle opener Clank oh okay Oh a spoon
all right all right I got a spoon oh
here we are me we can take turns
oh well done that looks done I was
talking to somebody else about this now
like you should just like play a board
game that's a good idea
you know I think the first few
legitimately want to get to know it
could be really fun for you to talk
about why you've item over and even ask
his advice so pretty much what I've been
doing the past week I've been trying to
make friends
mm-hmm it's hard to accept that people
would want to be my friend I fail you
you're a cool guy that you know I like
you're a serial killer
you're pretty extroverted I'm an
extrovert and introvert I get my energy
from a lone time but then when I'm
around people it's like it's on let's go
but that like drains you really drains
me Wow I would never thought that of you
yeah that's a misconception piers Cheers
and that's great yeah this is Ben coming
over dude of course I really like it
there's awkward moments in almost every
day and throughout the week I noticed
you were starting to hold awkward
moments more lightly when I first heard
the challenges that Keith gave me I was
terrified I feel like I gained faith in
people when I'm focusing on the other
person more than I am myself that's when
I can be a better friend feel like a
different person
wow that's great it was really great why
they love you thank you so much very fun
yeah to make a friend I feel like I have
to kind of force them to my friend like
trick them trick people and be your
friend
that's so much effort it really is you
don't understand how hard this is